I'm on top of a hill and like 6,000
other hills and high places across the
United Kingdom this one has one of these
on top of it a short squat pillar made
of concrete about three feet high now
why would someone go to the trouble of
building six thousand odd trig points
they're known trigonometric stations on
high points because getting there is
incredibly difficult
you have to lug tools you have to lug
the concrete and you're building
something by the look of it that's kind
of last for centuries why would you do
that well the answer is mapping in 1936
and continuing for a quarter of a
century brigadier Martin Houghton and
thousands of people who worked the
Ordnance Survey built these pillars in
the tempt to retry angulate Great
Britain and produce the first truly
accurate map of the country see distance
is incredibly hard to measure but angles
angles you can do precisely on top of
here you've got some hooks on which you
can set down a theodolite something to
measure angles and then you build these
on hills so that no matter where you are
if you're at a trig point you can see at
least two other trig points and if you
can do that and you know high school
trigonometry then you can take one
precise baseline measurement across a
heat some where the angles you've
measured and work out the distance
across the entire United Kingdom
nowadays GPS has taken over of course a
little more than a landmark for Hill
walkers but nevertheless these trig
points meant that we had a precise map
of the United Kingdom with nothing more
than a lot of angles a lot of maths
you